I know that you know this but this is a
hot issue out here about the rich dudes
at Burning Man right naked are they
gonna break it yeah yeah and they really
sort of blew up in September what
happened is this woman wrote a sort of
tell-all account in September about her
experience working as a bartender and
server or she putted a Sherpa in this
burning man camp they call him Sherpas
yeah actually called the Sherpas there
yeah and Ervin said burning them right
and this portrait that she wrote was
incredibly unflattering and it turns out
the guy who organized this camp was a
guy named Jim Tannenbaum who is the
founder and CEO of foresight capital
which is a venture capital firm in San
Francisco not only that but he's also
recently had joined the board of
directors at the Burning Man project
which is a nonprofit organization that
runs this whole thing so when she wrote
this it just blew up and people were
furious about you know how this was
violating everything that Bernie man
stood for and not only is that this sort
of egregious you know invasion of the 1%
but it's also by this guy who's supposed
to be promoting the core Vernon Burning
Man values well and those Burning Man
values are I think I think they're cool
and it's an internet thing and I talked
to people go to Burning Man and come
back in their lives or they really feel
like their lives are changed yeah you
set up priorities or reconnecting with
their core priorities and bright people
have this you know serious experience
when they go to this yeah yeah and one
of the ten principles and I think the
one that was really at stake here is
sort of the idea of radical
self-reliance that everybody that goes
there has to participate volunteer do
things for themselves and in the past
it's not you know wealthy people have
always been going to Burning Man but
what people liked about it was there was
sort of this leveling effect that you
know even if you're a captain of
industry or celebrity you throw on your
costume you go out there you party like
everybody else you cook your meals like
everybody else and what upset people a
lot of it about this camp was that you
know there was a you know staff of you
know dozens of employees anyone that
paid for the camp they had to pay about
sixteen thousand five hundred dollars
for the week they were given wristbands
anybody who didn't have a wristband
wasn't
necessarily welcome inside the camp to
get drinks and there was a sort of you
know exclusivity that really bothered
people I mean that's one thing to throw
a lot of money and spend a lot of money
in the burger man camp but if you do
that you know you're supposed to sort of
welcome everybody in and then make it
open it's one right be rich is another
thing to wall yourself off at Burning
Man yeah you know we did this story last
year around this house burning though
what about this documentary spark mm-hmm
they've got a lot of attention on
Showtime and and it really sort of
represented what the sort of core spirit
of Burning Man yep all the way back to
when it was on a beach in San Francisco
and that really captured the magic of it
but I wonder if because the magic is so
magical that the that the you know more
disgusting aspects aren't really coming
out about Burning Man yeah well in some
ways it reminds me have a lot of stores
where you see these you know a little
startup you know in the operation that
has these core values and then suddenly
it explodes it gets bigger and bigger
and how do you maintain those values for
the story I ended up interviewing Larry
Harvey is one of the cofounders of
Burning Man and he was really
interesting his point was essentially
yeah you know some of these camps are
kind of distasteful to us but you know
from his perspective he'd rather have
you know the 1% coming to Burning Man
because ultimately he feels like Burning
Man will change them more than they
change Burning Man
well that's interesting with an
optimistic point of view
have you been Felix I have not no
although this made me very curious I
think we should definitely be there this
summer oh yeah I don't know if I'm gonna
pull that off it's a it's a fascinating
thing and it really is what's
interesting to me is that the technology
community here at the very very highest
levels people whose name I promise not
to say but CEOs is yeah some of the very
biggest companies in all of Silicon
Valley are both part of that rich man's
row there at Burning Man but really take
this very seriously yeah feel like
they're inspired by it yeah and it is a
great thing man it's you know the
creative spirit you know the art cars
you see that what people build there
it's unbelievable some of the things
that people are making out in the desert
and again as long as you know you're
willing to share everything you build
with everybody else I think people are
happy to have you know the
taxi iou's come out there it's it's the
you know bringing sort of the you know
one person that was at this camp and
found it distasteful was describing it
to me is sort of like bringing in an LA
nightclub or a Las Vegas nightclub into
the middle of Burning Man and I think
that's really what people you know whose
piss people off the most about this and
made it into such a controversy is fine
welcome come out to Burning Man
everyone's welcome it's the spirit of
inclusivity but when you're there you
got it you got to be open to everybody
you got to share everything and